[Musik]
der UN-Generalsekretär Antonio guteres
hat zum Auftakt der un-generaldebatte
vor allem Winter des weltweiten Unmuts
gewarnt die staatlich Übernahme des
angeschlagenen gasimporteurs ohne ein
paar steht offenbar unmittelbar bevor
und damit herzlich Willkommen zu Film
nach acht meine Gäste heute Abend sind
sie kennen ihn schon CDU-Politiker und
Kanzler der Herzen Wolfgang Bosbach ich
freue mich sehr er sich sicher die
dehnustrialisierung Deutschlands
gefährdet den Sozialstaat wir werden
sehen ob das stimmt Moderatorin und
Unternehmerin Charlotte würdig
beschäftigt die verstärkte
abtreibungsregeln Ungarn sie sieht die
Gefahr eines Rechtsrucks in Europa
FDP-Generalsekretär Bijan Jägerei treibt
die Energiekrise um seine Forderung die
drei sicheren Atomkraftwerke müssen am
Netz bleiben last but not least NZZ
politikredakteur und will nach acht
Stammgast Alexander Kistler er wird
heute Abend über die migrationskrise
aufklären er findet es nämlich
merkwürdig dass niemand über diese
spricht bevor ich nun mit meiner These
starte gibt es heute aber erstmal einen
Buchtipp und zwar das ein Buch von
Wolfgang Bosbach ich kann es Ihnen sehr
empfehlen ist noch nicht auf dem Markt
kommt aber jetzt der Titel wer glaubt
uns noch warum Politik an Vertrauen
verliert und was wir dagegen tun können
Sie wissen nicht empfindlich so oft
Bücher das hier habe ich aber schon
gelesen am Wochenende und Sie sollten es
auch tun Prädikat lesenswert meine These
heute Abend ist aber eine andere auch
wenn ich gerne überall Boss Box Buch
sprechen würde aber sie ist eher
tagesaktuell und das ist stoppt die
maskenpflicht für unsere alten ich weiß
ich sollte endlich mit dem Thema Masken
aufhören mir raten auch schon Freunde
ich sei vielleicht etwas verfolgt von
den Masken und ich glaube sie haben auch
recht ich verstehe dass ich da Menschen
Sorgen um mich machen aber ich habe sehr
wenig Verständnis dafür dass nicht alle
Bürger beim Anblick der maskenlosen
Politiker auf dem Oktoberfest auf die
Barrikaden gehen während es Kinder gibt
die den Schulen mit Maske sitzen müssen
also Shira wahnsinn was in diesem Land
vorgeht aber was für mich besonders
grotesk ist die Menschen in Altenheimen
werden zur Maske wieder gezwungen und
das wie ich ja dann finde in den eigenen
vier Wänden schließlich leben sie ja
dort diese Regel um gilt ab dem 1
Oktober 2022 und zwar für die Bewohner
von Alteneinrichtungen
Pflegeeinrichtungen in einer Zeit in der
Länder wie England Frankreich oder
Amerika die Pandemie für beendet erklärt
haben begründet wird das mit dem Schutz
der vulnerablen Gruppe aber ich möchte
einmal reinhören wie Justizminister
Marco Buschmann uns das denn erklärt
warum ist dieses Paket maßvoll
das einzige was ja wir für den Herbst
Winter über das hinaus was bekannt ist
qualitativ wirklich als
Bundesgesetzgeber einheitlich anordnen
sind ja die höheren Sicherheitsstandards
in den Krankenhäusern in den
Altenpflegeheimen das einzige also das
einzige was überhaupt noch passiert ist
ist ja mal so nebenbei erklärt ist also
die Situation in Altenheim und ich komme
natürlich nicht drumherum hier direkt
die Frage an Herrn Jägerei zu stellen
der ist ja der Generalsekretär der FDP
Herr Saray ist es denn überspitzt wenn
ich sage dass die Bewohner in alten- und
Pflegeheimen also Maske bei sich zu
Hause tragen müssen also zunächst einmal
muss ich den Kollegen Buschmann
verteidigen das habe ich mir gedacht sie
dürfen nicht vergessen mit wem er
verhandeln musste er hat mit Herrn
Lauterbach verhindert sie kennen die
Position der FDP
schon sehr viele Erfolge erzielt worden
aber in einer Welt wo die FDP die
absolute Mehrheit hätte würde vermutlich
einen mit Sicherheit ein
Infektionsschutzgesetz anders aussehen
als heute aber hier musste mit Herrn
Lauterbach verhandelt werden wir sind in
einer Koalition da müssen auch
konsenslösungen zustande kommen und das
ist halt das was man gemeinsam
vereinfacht aber ich muss kurz
unterbrechen hat man dem Lauterbach nein
ich muss kurz darüber hat man den
Lauterbach also als Geschenk die alten
gegeben so wie ich vielleicht das Buch
von Herrn Bosbach würde Geschenke dass
Sie heute hier ist es gibt ja eine ganze
Reihe von Entwicklung die auch
stattfinden wer hätte beispielsweise vor
kurzem gedacht dass beim Thema Maske im
Flugverkehr sich was tun wird dann gab
es dann diese Bilder wo eine
Empörungswelle erkennbar war und
plötzlich war man zugänglich für die
Argumente der FDP die man vorher
komplett ignoriert hatte und sie haben
ja auch eingangs diese Bilder vom
Oktoberfest gezeigt ich bin nicht
glücklich über diese Bilder ich war sehr
glücklich ich meine jetzt kein
bestimmtes Bild will auch jetzt
niemanden kritisieren nur es ist immer
auch schwierig für das Ansehen der
Politik wenn man Dinge beschließt aber
nach außen der Eindruck entsteht die
stehen selbst nicht dazu und dann haben
wir ein Problem beim Thema
Glaubwürdigkeit der Politik aber noch
einmal für uns war völlig klar wir sind
in einer neuen Phase der Pandemie die
Instrumente die in der Vergangenheit
möglicherweise funktioniert haben die
gelten heute nicht mehr und es war uns
als FDP unheimlich wichtig zu sagen wir
wollen alle Instrumente der ersten Phase
der Pandemie einmal evaluieren einmal
bewerten damit die Wissenschaft basiert
am möglicherweise auch Überlegungen
entwickelt werden können für eine
mögliche neue Welle oder neue Phase der
Pandemie eine Sache war für uns da
besonders wichtig wir haben gesagt
Freiheitseinschränkung so im Vorort
voraus wird es nicht geben und das
Prinzip der verhältnismäß Möglichkeit
muss hoch gehalten werden
wir haben das bei jeder Gelegenheit
gesagt nicht die Freiheit muss begründet
werden sondern die Einschränkung somit
sind wir auch in dieser Diskussion am
Rhein
eröffnen dann noch mal wirklich die
Frage an Sie stellen ich finde wirklich
und mir wird wirklich schlechter dabei
wenn ich daran denke dass also
eigentlich jeder jetzt endlich mal ohne
Maske rumlaufen darf aber die alten in
Pflege und Altenheim die sollen die
Maske auflassen und dann sagen sie
eigentlich ja man musste er Lauterbach
rausgehen doch gerade eine völlig die
völlig falsche Person an der Stelle also
ich weiß nicht wie viele Einladung an
Herr Lauterbach geschickt haben mal hier
in dieser Sendung zu kommen ja aber dann
sollte man diese Leute dann die Fragen
stellen also wir waren diejenigen die
bei diesem Thema beim
Infektionsschutzgesetz für gegen die
Freiheitseinschränkung gekämpft haben
im Altenheim und den Pflegeeinrichtungen
noch mal es ist ich will das jetzt nicht
in einer Sendung im Fernsehen aufmachen
etwas was in der Koalition vereinbart
wurde dann werde ich auch ein verdammt
Generalsekretär aber jeder der in den
letzten Wochen Monaten sich die Position
der FDP angeschaut hat weiß ganz genau
mit welcher Haltung die FDP in diese
Verhandlung reingegangen ist und es ist
einfach nicht realistisch von der FDP zu
erwarten dass man sich hundertprozentig
dann auch durchsetzt die Mehrheit haben
wir leider noch nicht denn frage ich
einmal Herrn Bosbach wie sehen Sie das
denn wir empfinden sie das mit Blick auf
die Pflege und Altenheim das ja die
Bewohner quasi in den eigenen vier
Wänden zur Maske gezwungen werden
tun möchte der mag es tun aber ich bin
gegen einen Zwang und ich
Eigenverantwortung die eigene
Verantwortung weil die Situationen in
den alten Wohn- und Pflegeheimen sich
sehr ähneln dürft Mama ist in einer
solchen Einrichtung geht es stramm auf
den 95 lebensjahr zu ist geimpft die
Pflegekräfte tragen alle Masken von der
Arzt kommt trägt er eine Maske und Du
darfst Mutter nur besuchen wenn du dich
vorher hat hast testen lassen und zwar
24 Stunden vorher nicht irgendwann also
ein relativ hoher Sicherheitsstandard
und ich glaube Mama wird tot unglücklich
sein jetzt zu Hause keine Maske getragen
obwohl er kam der mobile Pflegedienst er
kam der Masseur da kam der Arzt da kam
der Friseur der Haushaltshilfe
hat ist nichts passiert in all der Zeit
ich glaube für die für Mama wäre es eine
wirkliche Belastung wenn das jetzt ab 1
Oktober was tun möchte mag es tun also
Flugzeug hat mich jetzt ebenso positiv
überrascht wie gewundert denn im Zug
sitzt du ja viel enger im Flugzeug sitzt
du viel enger als im Zug dann wird
gesagt aber der Luftaustausch in einem
Flugzeug ist intensiver als in einer
Bahn
bei der letzten Fahrt waren wir zu zweit
in einem Abteil zu zweit und der Kollege
der 20 Meter von mir entfernt ist Barsch
aufgefordert worden doch bitte die Maske
zu tragen hat dann Getränk bestellt und
hat dann so für 0,24 Stunden gebraucht
weil er nicht die Maske anhaben wollte
also wegen mir hätte sie ich habe sie
brav getragen wir können uns ja gar
nichts erlauben ja wir müssen ja davor
Bild sein also als Politiker ein Vorbild
wenn sie sagen mit zwei Leuten in der
Bahn wissen Sie was ich mache es nicht
mehr Regeln sind dafür da dass man sie
einhält und wenn wir es nicht tun wir
wie können wir es dann erwarten bei
Ihnen sagen die Leute werden sagen der
kann sich als Generalsekretär mehr
herausnehmen als wir nee kann man nicht
weil er unter verschärfter öffentlicher
Beobachtung da steht ob es sinnhaft ist
dahinter mal ein dickes Fragezeichen
aber sagen Sie es doch ruhig wenn ich
alleine entschieden hätte ich hätte es
nicht gemacht aber wir mussten uns in
der Koalition beugen so so ist das Leben
mussten wir auch früher naja wir haben
ja auch einiges durchgesetzt also ist ja
jetzt nicht so dass Herr Lauterbach sich
durchgesetzt hat also es ist ja schon
wie gesagt wir haben mit Herrn
Lauterbach verhandelt
sagen keine getragen dementsprechend
keine lockdowns mehr keine
Schulschließungen mehr also das sind ja
Dinge das wird heute als
selbstverständlich dargestellt glauben
Sie mir als jemand der die Verhandlung
mitbekommen hat das war nicht
selbstverständlich Frau würdig wie
nehmen sie denn die aktuelle Lage in
Deutschland wahr bezüglich der
corona-regeln ab dem 1 Oktober erst
einmal viel durcheinander und erst
einmal tatsächlich
erstmal lese ich mir das jetzt durch
oder warte ich noch mal zwei Wochen weil
sie ändert sich sowieso alles also man
hat so ein bisschen den
die du Lust verloren sich damit wirklich
auseinanderzusetzen natürlich atme ich
auf als zweifachmutter wenn ich lese es
gibt keine Schulschließungen mehr glaube
ich nein weil das muss ja jetzt so
irgendwas passieren und dann greift
natürlich eine andere Wort oder andere
Handlung dass man sagt jetzt müssen wir
für die Schulen schließen
nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich das letzte
Vertrauen natürlich nicht verlieren was
im Moment sowieso schwierig ist generell
betrachtet und deshalb bin ich ja froh
dass man überhaupt so in der Regelung
gekommen ist und was Altersheime
betrifft natürlich wäre das wahnsinnig
traurig wenn die
alten Menschen dort im Altersheim Masken
tragen müssen es liegt an uns wenn wir
in ein Altersheim betreten dann haben
wir eine Maske zu tragen wir haben uns
vorher testen zu lassen und dann können
wir dafür sorgen dass die da eine gute
normale Zeit haben das liegt ganz an uns
finde ich also sie sind auch dagegen
dass die Bewohner von Altenpflegeheimen
kriegen und das irgendwann reicht es
auch mal es ist irgendwie also das ist
genauso wie die Entscheidung
fünfklässler sollen Masken tragen aber
Viertklässler nicht
ich habe jetzt aufgegeben bestimmte
Sachen zu hinterfragen weil ich werde es
nicht verstehen haben sie auch ihre
Meinung in manchen Sachen geändert sie
hatten ja letztes Jahr für Furore
gesorgt als sie gegen die ungeimpften
haben sie gesagt in den würden sie jetzt
nicht Weihnachten feiern wollen haben
sie da auch ihre Meinung geändert oder
hat ihn der Verlauf Corona hat sich auch
verändert auch gezeigt dass man seine
Meinung ändern kann ich habe das nie
gesagt ach so nein überhaupt ja das habt
ihr geschrieben
aber man muss dazu sagen also das steht
nicht zwischen uns oder sowas ne aber
Fakt ist einfach ich habe gesagt ich
würde ich hatte Corona mit meinen beiden
Jungs zusammen zu Hause zwei Wochen und
das war die absolute Hölle und das
möchte ich niemanden zutrauen der sich
nicht hat impfen lassen falls ich noch
ansteckend sein sollte ach so das ist
ehrlich gesagt wirklich was anderes ja
ganz andere Fakt ja absolut ich habe
also absolute wer sich nicht impfen
lassen möchte soll es halt nicht tun
also das ist dann darum kann ich mich
jetzt auch noch kümmern deswegen also da
eigentlich das Prinzip Freiheit und
Eigenverantwortung gelebt
Eigenverantwortung klar dass es immer
leicht gesagt das muss man natürlich
auch irgendwie auch leben und also man
sollte sich schon ein Beispiel nehmen
und ein bisschen gucken und überlegen wo
man lebt was man macht wie soll man das
braucht dass das auf jeden Fall schon ja
Herr Kistler wie sehen Sie das denn das
infektionenschutzgesetz ab 1 Oktober auf
Twitter sind sie ja sehr rege gegen die
corona-maßnahmen unterwegs definitiv
also natürlich hat jetzt der Kollege von
der FDP jetzt sehr erlernt die
Verhandlungserfolge der FDP im Angesicht
des übermächtigen dreimal groß
gotthaften Karl Lauterbach geschildert
aber im Ergebnis ist es natürlich immer
noch ein Schritt hinter den
Freiheitsgraden zurück die eigentlich
vernünftig wäre ich meine wenn selbst
der amerikanische Präsident Joe Biden
der das weiß ich sechs sieben acht Jahre
alt ist 78 glaube ich sagt die Pandemie
ist vorbei dann gibt es eigentlich für
keine einzige Einschränkung mehr ein
vernünftigen Grund mehr und wenn ich
höre dass sogar im
Infektionsschutzgesetz dass sie jetzt
hier als maßvollen Kompromissen
anpreisen drin gestanden hat bis vor der
Verhandlung im dort das Covic 19 eine
Reihe aufzuführen sei mit mit Scharlach
glaube ich mit Scharlach kollerwagen
ganz schlimm Krankheiten wurde später
aber noch verhindert nachdem es bereits
erklären wegen gewissermaßen gehabt
hatte also ich meine man kann immer
sagen wir haben das Schlimmste
verhindert da stimme ich Ihnen zu also
ein Land in dem Karl Lauterbach regieren
würde wäre ich schon ausgewandert das
ist richtig dennoch ist es natürlich auf
lange Sicht für eine selbstbewusste
Partei auch wenn sie nur die Kleine ist
innerhalb einer Kollation etwas zu wenig
zu sagen wählt uns weil wir das
Schlimmste verhindern ich glaube etwas
mehr traute muss ich dann manchmal schon
geben und man sieht ja momentan auch
dass die Menschen sich an viele Vorgaben
intuitiv nicht mehr so halten wie es im
Infektionsschutzgesetz steht
Infektionsschutzgesetz steht Gesetz
steht ich habe heute auch gemerkt in der
U-Bahn Berlin tragen vielleicht 60 70%
noch die Maske ist wenn glaube ich jede
Woche fünf sechs Prozent weniger was
haben wir dann von einem Gesetz zu einer
Verordnung das Schleichen in der
Realität beerdigt wird weil es keine
Bindekraft mehr hat ich will ja nicht
ich will ja nicht sagen jeder soll jetzt
rumrennen und sagen Danke FDP aber
hätten Sie
aber man muss schon anerkennen dass
seitdem die FDP in der
Regierungsverantwortung ist eine andere
pandemiepolitik in Deutschland herrscht
da sollte man fair sein wir haben gerade
auch wir haben gerade über die äh an die
impfpflichtdebatte erinnert welche
Partei hat das in letztendlich
verhindern aber entschuldigung aber
trotzdem ich frage mich auch manchmal
von der was für eine Erwartungshaltung
hier gegenüber der FDP formuliert wird
das ist ja absolut nicht realistisch
noch mal wir haben nicht die absolute
Mehrheit in Deutschland
wir haben eine ganz andere Pandemie
Politik in diesem Land etabliert als
bisher existiert hatte nur einfach mal
sachlich nüchtern an diese Zeit
Erwartungshaltung ist dass die FDP in
der Regierung genau das macht was sie im
Wahlkampf versprochen hat das haben wir
auch gemacht das überrascht mich dass
sie das jetzt sagen ja
wartungshaltung des Publikums gegenüber
allen Parteien meine Sorge ist eine
andere ich gehe mal davon aus dass wir
mit der Ende mit der en genau leben
müssen natürlich dass wir aber dann nie
mehr herauskommen aus den
Schutzmaßnahmen weil es immer wieder
neue Fälle geben wird so wie es auch
trotz Grippeschutzimpfung immer wieder
Grippe erkrankt hat
immer wieder wir sind im Übergang von
der Pandemie zu einer endemischen
Entwicklung und wenn wir das zum Maßstab
machen solange wir noch Corona Fälle
haben an nennenswerte zahlen müssen wir
immer Schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen das ist
meine Befürchtung dass wir dann aus dem
Kreislauf nicht mehr herauskommt die
Befürchtung nehmen wir jetzt mit und
gehen jetzt weiter zum Thema von Herrn
Kissler da geht es nicht um Corona
sondern um Migration ja ich habe eine
Nachricht mitgebracht die ist nicht sehr
schön aber sehr wichtig und sie lautet
die migrationskrise ist zurück wir
dachten wir hätten sie bewältigt aber
wir haben sie befürchte ich nur
verdrängt und im Stundentakt gehen nun
Hilfe rufe ein aus den Ländern aus den
Kommunen Hilferufe aus Thüringen zum
Beispiel aus Hamburg ein ganz
dramatischer hilfe-appell kann Sachsen
wo der neue Innenminister Schuster mit
Namen von der CDU gesagt hat wir halten
das nicht mehr aus 80% der
erstaufnahmeplätze sind bereits belegt
in der ersten Jahreshälfte sagte
Schuster kam im Schnitt 500 Menschen im
Monat nach Sachsen für den September
befürchtete der über 3000 das ist eine
versetzfachung und herr Schuster sagt
auch liebe Bundesregierung redet bitte
mit Polen und Tschechien weil es handelt
sich in vielen Fällen um
sekundärmigrationen es gibt Menschen die
aus Polen und Tschechien kommen aus
sicheren Drittstaaten um in Deutschland
Asyl zu beantragen noch schlimmere
Nachrichten gab es aus Bayern dort
lassen wir heute in der Süddeutschen
Zeitung zu 105% sind dort die
erstaufnahmeplätze belegt zu 105 Prozent
man befürchtet den sozialen Frieden und
ganz besonders dramatisch hörte ich nun
aus einem anderen Bundesland aus dem
schönen Baden-Württemberg dort hat sich
der Landrat von Tübingen zu Wort
gemeldet der gleichzeitig auch dem Land
des Kreistag vorsteht und er hat gesagt
ich zitiere ihn wir locken die
Flüchtlinge in sein Wort Zitat soziale
Hängematte und der hat auf Gespräche
verwies mit ukrainischen Männern die ihm
gesagt haben wir leben und arbeiten seit
Jahr und Tag in Polen aber wir holen
unsere Familien nach ziehen nach
Deutschland und in Deutschland bekommen
wir fürs nichts tun mehr Geld als fürs
Arbeiten in Polen insofern muss ich
leider der Regierung vorwerfen dass sie
die migrationskrise verschläft ja mehr
noch dass sie den migrationsturbo wieder
anschlägt nämlich mit dem Bürgergeld das
Bürgergeld soll nun kommen zum ersten
Januar dann könnte eine fünfköpfige
Familie 2000 Euro monatlich bekommen und
ersetzt bekommen auch noch die warnmiete
im Monat das heißt die migrationskrise
kommt der migrationsturbonames
Bürgergeld wird neu angeworfen das ist
leider schlecht für alle Beteiligten für
die Menschen die zu uns kommen für die
Menschen die hier leben es ist schlecht
für die SPD weil sie damit das
sozialdemokratische aufstiegsversprechen
beerdigt es ist schlecht für die FDP
weil sie Abschied nimmt vom liberalen
Menschenbild und es spricht für die
Ampel weil sie einfach schlecht regiert
und leider Gottes nicht die Interessen
derer im Blick hat die sie gefördert im
Blick haben sollte der Steuerzahler
insofern ist es leider momentan ein
Trauerspiel Herr Kessler ist das Bild
was sie gerade über die Migration
gezeichnet haben nicht fast gefährlich
Schrägstrich Populismus wenn man sieht
also es gibt gewisse Studien die sagen
wir brauchen 400.000 Zuwanderer pro Jahr
müssten wir da nicht eher sagen okay
großartig dass Menschen zu uns kommen
und im nächsten Schritt wie schaffen wir
es jetzt sie zu motivieren die einen
hier genannt worden sind von dem Landrat
auf den ich bezogen habe sind die Leute
die hier gar nicht arbeiten wollen also
wir brauchen natürlich Fachkräfte das
ist richtig aber wir brauchen natürlich
nicht eine ungeordnete eine irreguläre
Migration wir brauchen keine
sekundär-migration innerhalb der EU wer
in sicheren Drittstaaten ist wie in
Spanien wie in Polen wie in Portugal wie
in Tschechien der sucht sich a la carte
gewissermaßen das Land aus wo er meint
die besten Verhältnisse vorzufinden das
ist völlig rational es ist kein
vorzuwerfen aber die Ampel sitzt leider
die völlig falschen Anreiz man müsste
Fachkräfte Migration durch Initiativen
anfordern aber stattdessen haben wir
leider Gottes eine ungeordnete Migration
das ist nicht populistisch das sind
Zahlen die ich genannt habe die
Wirklichkeit kann die populistisch sein
Populismus wäre es wenn man sich vor der
Wirklichkeit verschließt hätte sehr reif
verschließt sich die Ampel vor der
Wirklichkeit also zunächst einmal ich
würde ich würde davor warnen diese
Debatten als populistisch zu betrachten
ich finde ich finde man sollte schon
auch über diese Themen gerade in der
heutigen Zeit sehr intensiv diskutieren
es sind natürlich jetzt drei
verschiedene Themen die in einem
Zusammenhang diskutiert wurden
Fachkräfte würde ich sagen ja wir
brauchen attraktive Fachkräfte für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland für
unsere eigene Volkswirtschaft für die
Zukunft unseres Landes allerdings machen
wir dort nach wie vor die Erfahrung dass
richtig gut ausgebildete Leute leider
sich immer noch zu wenig für Deutschland
interessieren sondern eher für Länder
wie USA Kanada oder Australien aber
weniger für Deutschland daran müssen wir
arbeiten daran müssen wir auch
systematisch Arbeiten der zweite Punkt
ist natürlich die Einwanderung in die
sogenannten sozialen Systeme das ist
etwas was natürlich außerordentlich
problematisch ist denn ja Fachkräfte ja
aber diese Form der Zuwanderung brauchen
wir definitiv nicht und darum jetzt noch
diese von dem Thema zu dem Thema komme
ich auch nur weil ich glaube das wäre
nicht so ein ganz fair wenn man das
Vermischen würde
selbstverständlich ist es richtig dass
man dass der Staat keine andere keine
Anreize setzen darf damit Zuwanderung in
die sozialen Kassen in die sozialen
Systeme stattfindet
da muss der Staat aufpassen diese Form
der Zuwanderung wäre übrigens auch
außerordentlich problematisch das ist
auch Zuwanderung würde ich sagen
grundsätzlich ist es gut wenn die
Integration gelingt wenn die Integration
nicht gelingt ist Zuwanderung natürlich
ein großes Problem dann das andere Thema
Bürgergeld
so ähnlich wie das Thema was wir gerade
eben auch bisschen diskutiert haben
Corona und ich wiederhole meinen Satz ja
ist auch
abholen was jetzt mit dem Bürgergeld
passiert vielleicht hat das noch nicht
jeder mitbekommen was jetzt die Änderung
ist also im Grunde genommen das was
früher als äh Hartz IV bezeichnet wurde
wird ab dem ersten ersten basierend
das ist ja im Koalitionsvertrag ja so
vereinbart worden wird demnächst
Bürgergeld heißen also Hartz IV
überwinden Bürgergeld zum Weg zum
Bürgergeld wir haben aber festgestellt
dass wir uns einig sind in der Koalition
was den Namen anbetrifft aber die
Vorstellung was ein Bürgergeld kann oder
leisten soll ist innerhalb der Koalition
total unterschiedlich gewesen
Koalitionspartner die Bürgergeld
gleichgesetzt haben mit
bedingungsloses in die Richtung kommst
die Sanktionen gibt es die Sanktionen
wurden ausgesetzt und vor allem das
einzige das einzige was sich verändert
hat an der Stelle sind die Regelsätze
die Regelsätze geändert worden die sind
nicht erhöht worden da muss man so fair
sein die sind nur
aber Sie müssen doch erkennen dass wir
derzeit eine Inflation
wir haben beim Thema
Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten was gemacht das
da sind Erweiterungen gegeben wir haben
beim Thema Qualifizierung was gemacht es
ist auch nicht falsch es ist auch völlig
falsch was die Union im Deutschen
Bundestag erzählt das Prinzip Fördern
und Fordern bleibt weiterhin bestehen
es müssen Anreize vorhanden sein damit
Menschen aus der Arbeitslosigkeit auch
herauskommen wer arbeitet und das war
die Vorgabe der FDP bei den
Verhandlungen wer arbeitet muss mehr
haben als jemanden nicht erreicht das
soll er sagt nein Roßbach Herr Bosbach
wie sehen Sie denn das Bürgergeld also
ist schon mal nicht geändert das wird
sie doch schon mal freuen
wir mal vorne an es wird immer gesagt
500 €. damit wird der Eindruck erweckt
dass derjenige der Bürgergeld jetzt
bezieht
Monat nur 500 Euro zur Verfügung hätte
und dann kommt der Nachsatz wie will man
denn davon leben nehmen wir mal ein paar
mit zwei Kindern die plus Kosten der
Unterkunft die kommen locker auf einem
Betrag zwischen 2000 und
zweieinhalbtausend was aus der Sicht der
Empfänger netto ist die Heizkosten
werden übernommen Kosten der Unterkunft
und das sind dann die die mitnehmen
Kosten so jetzt muss ich darüber
überlegen lohnt es wirtschaftlich lohnt
es sich aus der aus den Sozialleistungen
herauszugeben und in eine Beschäftigung
hereinzugehen die Betroffenen werden ihr
jetziges staatliches Einkommen nicht
vergleichen mit ihrem zukünftigen
Bruttoeinkommen sondern mit dem
zukünftigen Nettoeinkommen wenn sie zwei
Kinder haben sind die Regelsätze für die
Kinder höher als das staatliche
Kindergeld was sie bezieht wenn sie in
eine Beschäftigung gehen sehen wir mal
einen durchschnittliches Gehalt dann
werden Sie feststellen dass der dass die
Differenz vielleicht zwei drei 400 Euro
ist im Monat Berechnungen und dann
stellen sich viele die Frage lohnt sich
das sie haben recht es ist eine
Angleichung an die sehr hohe
Inflationsrate ja das Glück haben die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer aber
nicht sondern die müssen dann dem Wege
des Tarif aus Tarif Auseinandersetzung
oder des Streiks versuchen dass sie
keine reale dafür schaffen wir die kalte
Progression
das ist gerade geschehen Tarif auf
Rädern ändert aber nichts daran dass sie
für jede Lohnerhöhung streiten müssen
während das durch den Gesetzgeber hier
beim Hartz IV Bürgergeld per Gesetz
nachgeholt worden ist wenn sie den
Menschen den Anreiz nehmen in eine
Beschäftigung hereinzugehen wird es auch
viele die zu uns kommen dass keine Frage
der Ethnie keine Frage der Herkunft
werden viele Feststellungen wie viel es
in Deutschland gibt weitaus mehr als in
den Herkunftsländern mit einer
Beschäftigung
wobei ist davon gehe ich auch zur
Ehrenrettung der Betroffenen es wird
auch viele geben sehr viele die sagen es
ist für mich eine Frage der würde ich
möchte gar nicht kommen
in diesem Land aber ich bin fassungslos
dass sie jetzt hier erzählen es hält
sich ansonsten nichts geändert wir haben
schon Vermögen von 150.000 Euro
150.000 Euro wir haben auch zwei Wagen
wenn wenn wenn wenn zweifache Brust
Tätigkeit macht so schon Vermögen das
heißt obwohl sie ein Vermögen haben von
150.000 ein schönes Einfamilienhaus
bewohnt soll der Steuerzahler das
finanzieren der möglicherweise ein
geringeres Einkommen lassen und in den
ersten sechs Monaten soll es keine
Sanktionen geben mit
ausnahmetermin versäumt ist beim
Arbeitsamt es ist schon ein Unterschied
zu hat
sofort
Jobangebote ablegen nicht einhält wer
sich an Weiterbildungsmaßnahmen nicht
hält der wird selbstverständlich in
diesem System sanktioniert
selbstverständlich in diesem System
sanktioniert da war ich auch auf dem
Wissensstand von Herrn Bosbach
nein nein
Termine
teilen wäre jetzt recht hat am Tisch
aber Frau würde wie nehmen sie die
Stimmung war lohnt sich arbeiten noch
also ich finde grundsätzlich also das
muss sie sein diese Diskussion dreht
sich gerade sehr sehr schnell also wir
sind von hier Migration
setzen soll in diesem Moment und ich
höre und lerne gerade sehr viel ja ich
finde es ist auch in meiner
Verantwortung meine Kinder so zu
erziehen dass ich arbeiten lohnt weil
Arbeiten Spaß macht ja und es geht und
für mich ist es so dass ich auch sage
ich werde meinen Kindern auch einfach
beibringen zu sagen okay oder eher die
Richtung nicht zwingen du musst arbeiten
du musst was leisten muss Geld verdienen
sondern selbst rauszufinden was könnte
mir Spaß machen damit ich später das
Geld verdienen kann und das ist mir
wirklich Spaß macht das zu verdienen und
da sehe ich jetzt so meine Verantwortung
muss ich sagen was sie jetzt mit dem
anderen das überlasse ich erstmal ihnen
wir können ansprechen
alle die auf dem Land Wege kommen alle
ausnahmslos alle kommen ja aus sicheren
verfolgungsfreien EU-Staaten oder aus
der schnuckeligen Schweiz auch
unstreitig
befestigter demokratischer Staat sie
stammen aus anderen Ländern aber sie
kommen über verfolgungsfreie Staaten da
möchten Sie aber nicht bleiben sondern
sie möchten lieber nach Deutschland oder
über Deutschland weiterwandern auch
heute noch weisen wir niemanden an der
Grenze der einen Asylantrag stellt das
allerdings kann ich jetzt der Ampel
nicht Anlassen sondern das ist die
Politik seit Anfang September
2015 die CDU glaube ich im Kanzleramt ja
das war eine eine politische
Entscheidung dass wir jeden ins Land
lassen der einen Asylantrag stellt
natürlich weisen wir zurück wenn jemand
aus dem viralflichen Stadt kommt kein
Visum hat und sagt ich möchte gerne nach
Deutschland einreisen dann weisen wir
auch heute zurück wenn aber wieder kommt
und sagt jetzt stelle ich einen
Asylantrag dann aber
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
rückführungsoffensiv und ich finde
definitiv nicht statt das finden
wir zum Thema von Frau würdig das ist
nämlich auch sehr wichtig und jetzt
bleiben wir vielleicht auch mal bei dem
Thema es war gerade wirklich etwas
bunter alte Frau würde gerecht naja das
ist doch schön wir gucken mal was ich so
ergibt so also ich habe folgendes Thema
mitgebracht weil es meiner Meinung nach
komplett untergegangen ist und das darf
auf gar keinen Fall sein am 16 September
ist ein paar Tage zwei Jahre diesen
Jahres natürlich hat die Partei des
ungarischen Ministerpräsidenten Orban
ein ziemlich überraschendes Gesetz
erlassen die eine Abtreibung erschwert
bzw aus meiner Sicht sogar richtig
grotesk macht denn es verlangt
tatsächlich von der Frau dass sie sich
die Herztöne des Babys anhören muss dies
wiederum ärztlich bescheinigen lassen
muss bevor sie dann den schweren Weg
eine Abtreibung gehen darf und die
Begründung dazu die finde ich
noch schlimmer den Frauen würde auf
dieser Weise klar gemacht werden dass es
sich um ein Lebewesen handelt so das ist
für mich absolut unwürdig
Herr Boss ganz kurz Schule ja ich wollte
was mich nämlich total interessiert hat
als ich dieses Thema auf dieses Thema
gestoßen bin war
kannten sie das Thema kennen sie das
Thema kennen Sie diese Entscheidung
ich kannte sie bis heute nicht auch mit
den Details
gelesen ja und gelesen ja und das fanden
sie für heute Abend nicht
wichtiges Thema lustiges Thema ja also
ich persönlich finde natürlich dass eine
Abtreibung immer eine Niederlage ist für
beide Parteien also für den Menschen
heranwächst und für die Frau die sich
dazu entscheidet also ich finde jede
Abtreibung ist ist ein Tragödie
letztlich und hat hat keine Gewinner
andererseits ist es für ein liberalen
Rechtsstaat und da muss man natürlich
bei ungarnden Fragezeichen dran machen
schwierig da jetzt allzu intensiv da in
die Freiheitsrechte einzugreifen
generell finde ich Abtreibungen immer
immer schlimmer und naja also sie meinen
das ist halt Ungarn und dann ist es
Ungarn Sache so jetzt mal ganz salopp
gesagt auf der anderen Seite habt Ungarn
ja gerade eine
anti-abtreibungskampagne mit EU gehen
dann finanziert also ein bisschen sitzen
wir schon im gemeinsamen Boot finde ich
und der Grund warum ich das Frage ist
nicht weil ich jetzt irgendwie
Verantwortung hin und herschieben mich
einfach nur weil ich mich dieses Thema
was so wichtig ist werden halt von so
dominanten Männern entschieden und das
wundert mich halt auch sehr sehr stark
warum du da keine Frau hinzugezogen
warum ist es kein Frauenthema warum
verschwindet das warum ist es heute
Abend nicht hier ausprobieren
ich könnte aber auch die Gegenfrage
stellen warum ist noch nie das Thema
aufgerufen worden also in einem
wohlhabenden Land wir in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland jedes Jahr
10.000 Kinder nicht geboren werden
sondern abgetrieben werden wieso regt
sich darüber keine auf wieso ist das
hier kein Thema doch noch
Ungarn hat im Prinzip das gleiche Recht
wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
nämlich eine Fristenlösung mit
beratungszwang aber wir wären
richtigerweise in Deutschland nicht auf
die Idee gekommen eine solche Regelung
einzuführen wie jetzt das ungarische
Parlament das wird auch nicht kommen
Weise allerdings darauf und die
verschiedenen hat das gelesen in meinem
Buch dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht
gesagt hat dass ungeborene Leben hat die
gleiche Wertigkeit wie das geborene und
wir sind hier in dem Spannungsfeld
zwischen dem Selbstbestimmungsrecht der
Frau und dem Lebensrechtes noch
ungeborenen Kindes aber mit einer
Entwürdigung so haben sie es ja gerade
charakterisiert werden werden wir leben
nicht mehr schützen dass meine
Überzeugung sondern mit Hilfsangeboten
indem man die schwanger auch ermutigt
das Kind alles so tragen und sie in der
Not nicht alleine lässt und dann haben
wir uns nichts vormachen an dieser Not
sind auch auf die Jungs Schuld wir haben
Anfang dabei waren aber dann nichts mehr
damit zu tun haben wollen und ihre
schwangere Frau oder Freundin alleine
lassen in der Not und umso wichtiger
wäre Hilfe ich finde ich stimme ja da
absolut zu dass es gut ist dass es eine
Beratung vorher gibt die gibt es ja auch
in Ungarn es gibt die gibt es auch in
Deutschland das ist keine Frage aber
alles was hier drüber weggeht und da
sind wir hier bei dem sich die Herztöne
anhören müssen ist natürlich grotesk für
die Frau weil nur wenn ich das oder eine
Statistik zu kennen aber ich gehe davon
aus dass nur eine Minderheit einfach so
abtreibt und damit locker umgehen kann
ich habe das heute mal nachgeschaut die
meisten Frauen sind wirklich älter und
es ist auch oft gar nicht das erste Kind
also das Bild von der 18-Jährigen die
geschont werden muss und die nicht
weiter weiß das ist so natürlich auch da
aber nicht so existent es sind vor allem
die älteren und nicht die ganz Jungen
mit den Abtreibung finanzielle Angst ist
eine große Sache dann der Partner der
Ehe stimmt nicht das ist auch noch ein
großes Thema wurde oft das Grund
angegeben und
das ist dann ist es ja schön die Frau
wird danach nicht aufgefangen das kann
ich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen ich habe
zwei Fehlgeburten durchgemacht und weiß
wie das ist man wird danach einfach
wieder losgelassen und man wird nicht
aufgefangen das finde ich auch gerade in
ein Land wie Deutschland wahnsinnig zu
bemängeln das ist sehr sehr schade
nichtsdestotrotz geht's ja hier jetzt um
dieses Thema wie kann man sowas
entscheiden und das ist jetzt keine
vorwurfragen sondern eine
Verständnisfrage wie kommt jemand auf so
etwas so etwas zu entscheiden da ist da
doch eigentlich behandelt man somit auch
die Frau als zweite Klasse hätte diese
Reiter ist eine gute Frage warum geht
ein Politiker wie Orban zurück das ist
ja ein Zurückgehen eigentlich also
zunächst einmal bin ich Frau würde ich
sehr dankbar dass sie dieses Thema heute
haben hier
platziert
ich selbst hatte auch nicht viel von
diesem Thema mitbekommen wir reden
derzeit viel über Ungarn aber in einem
anderen Zusammenhang der Streit mit der
Europäischen Union wir reden viel über
das Thema Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Ungarn
wir reden weil die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
in Ungarn tatsächlich auch in Gefahr ist
und natürlich das Thema
Korruptionsbekämpfung in Ungarn das ist
derzeit ein Riesenthema verbunden auch
mit beihilfezahlungen die dann oder
Zahlung der Europäische Union die
derzeit gestoppt werden da bis Ungarn
auch
gewisse Lenkungsmaßnahmen vornimmt die
Debatte ich wusste dass eine solche
Debatte in Ungarn gibt aber die Details
waren mir nicht bekannt die habe ich
erst vor der Sendung einmal gegoogelt
und gelesen also an der Stelle vielen
Dank wir machen uns grundsätzlich große
Sorgen
was Herr urban insgesamt in Ungarn für
eine Politik betreibt und das ist etwas
was man auf völlig unterschiedlichen
Feldern beobachten kann es gibt Leute
die sagen das ist jetzt übertrieben wie
das in Resteuropa gesehen wird andere
sagen in Europa insgesamt sind
europäische Bürgerrechte und auch
Menschenrechte in Gefahr weil urban und
sein systemobern so muss man das auch
inzwischen sagen sich auch deutlich
derzeit von den Werten Europas entfernt
von daher wundert mich das auch nicht
dass man Debatten dieser Art hat aber
insgesamt waren unsere Debatten eher bis
jetzt fokussiert auf die politischen
Themen was Sie gesagt haben zu der Zahl
der Abtreibung ich glaube ist wieder
leicht angestiegen in Deutschland und
wir haben natürlich hier schon den
Wertungswiderspruch dass wir einerseits
eine relativ stabile Zahlen Abtreibung
haben und andererseits aber auch sehr
viele ungewohnt kinderlose Paare also
ich finde es wäre gut wenn man
digitalen verringern könnte also wenn
man stärker mit Adoptionen und mit dem
Auffangen von Schwangeren darauf
reagieren würde als wenn Abtreibung soll
für das kinderlose Ehepaar überspitzt
formuliert also zumindest ist es glaube
ich eine Option die glaube ich noch zu
wenig im Bewusstsein ist also wir haben
viele Paare die also sehr viel
unternehmen um aus ihrer ungewollten
Kinderlosigkeit herauszukommen bisschen
zu Adoptionen von kleinen Kindern aus
aller Herren Länder sage ich mal
teilweise auch mit halblegalen wegen und
gleichzeitig relativ stabile Zahl von
Abtreibung in Deutschland wo einige
denke ich aus ökonomischen Gründen auf
keinen Fall sein müssten gibt immer
wieder entweder Notlagen Gefahr für
dieses Leben der Mutter etc da würde ich
keinem rein reden aber das ist ein
Ungleichgewicht glaube ich in dieser
dieser ist keine Balance zwischen diesen
beiden Größen also mein Vorschlag laden
Sie den ungarischen Botschafter ein ja
sprechen Sie nicht über Ungarn sondern
sprechen Sie mit Ungarn Herr Dr görgers
der wird sicherlich kommen er resident
ja hier um die Ecke und Unter den Linden
und fragen Sie ihn doch mal nach den
Motiven was er sich davon darüber
spricht ich finde das generell schwierig
wenn die Betroffenen nicht dabei sind
wie kommen die dazu so etwas zu
entscheiden dann würde ich lieber mit
Ihnen diskutieren das ist ein sehr gutes
Ende zu dem Thema wir werden ihn
einladen und gehen eine ganz kurz
Unterbrechung und gleich geht's mit der
Energiekrise weiter
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfen
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht Privatjet Uschi
aber niemand von dem politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden die
Gesellschaft machen das quasi zu Manko
vielleicht einmal kurz anders also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
meinen Beifall in meiner lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
bitte ist Baden man muss da ganz klar
jetzt mal auch darüber sprechen dass es
einfach nicht fair ist und nicht richtig
durch die Aufgabe von Journalismus
einfach die die Verlautbarung der
Politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir haben den Faktencheck einmal
angeworfen und es ist so dass in den
ersten sechs Monaten deutlich mildere
Sanktionen gelten aber es gibt die wenn
man einen Termin verpasst es stimmt aber
dass sie sechs Monate eine Schonzeit
sind und danach die dann härter werden
können dementsprechend würde ich sagen
hatten eigentlich beide hier am Tisch
Recht und wir geben weiter zu Wolfgang
Bosbach und seinem Thema
dieses Thema habe ich auf die
Tagesordnung dieser Sendung gesetzt wann
ich heute morgen gelesen habe Robert
Habeck unser Wirtschaftsminister ist der
Meinung der Staat können nicht jede
gewinnerwachtung erfüllen oder
jeden Gewinnausfall ersetzen ja da hatte
100% Recht ich habe nur bei dieser
Wortmeldung des Wirtschaftsministers das
Gefühl dass der Fachkräftemangel
mittlerweile auch in der Bundesregierung
sitzt denn es geht nicht darum
Gewinnversprechen zu erfüllen durch den
Staat sondern es geht um die Existenz
unzähliger Betriebe in Deutschland wenn
sieben von zehn Betrieben bei einer
Umfrage zu Protokoll geben ihre
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit sei bei weiter
steigenden Energiepreisen akut gefährdet
dann befürchte ich eine schleichende die
Industrialisierung unseres Landes wenn
du ein Haus zerstören willst kannst du
die Abrissbirne nehmen das gibt einen
riesen Knall und dann liegt das Haus in
trümmert du kannst aber auch vom
gleichen Haus Stein für Stein wegnehmen
das ist unspektakulär aber nach einiger
Zeit ist das Ergebnis das gleiche und es
gibt einen untrennbaren Zusammenhang
zwischen der wirtschaftlichen
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Landes und
unserer sozialen Leistungsfähigkeit und
wenn unsere Betriebe nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig sind wenn sie nicht
mehr die notwendigen Innovationskraft
haben dann werden wir auch den
Sozialstaat nicht weiter festigen und
ausbauen können das ist meine Sorgen
Herr Weißbach mich hat auch schockiert
Herr Habeck hat ja dann auch gesagt dass
wir den Winter überstehen werden wenn
wir auch Glück mit dem Wetter haben
was haben Sie denn bei der Aussage
empfunden von der Arbeit kannst Du
darauf keine Politik aufbauen die
Gasspeicher sind zu über 90 Prozent
gefüllt allerdings bei einem normalen
Winter
es reicht das für Januar Februar wir
haben aber im März April auch schon
minus Temperaturen gab das ja keine
meteorologische Sensation und es die
Betriebe brauchen Sicherheit Sicherheit
in puncto Entsorgung das gilt natürlich
auch für die Haushalte aber jetzt
prozessguard was also für die
Herstellung von Gütern benutzt werden
muss in der Produktion bekomme ich die
ausreichende Menge oder muss ich meinen
Betrieb schließen ich gehe jetzt nicht
darauf ein
insolvenzbetriebsaufgabe das ist ja eine
andere Baustelle und wie sind denn die
Preise das sind ja zwei verschiedene
Baustellen die gasumlage kommt ja noch
on top jetzt hat ja mittlerweile er
Habeck selber die Befürchtung dass es
hier verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken
geben könnte das klammern wir auch mal
aus aber wenn unsere Betriebe keine
Sicherheit haben dass sie die Energie
bekommen die sie brauchen oder zur
exorbitanten Preisen die sie dann in
ihren Preisen an die Kunden nicht
weitergeben können dann geraten die
Betriebe in Not deswegen muss der Staat
helfen so wie er es bei Corona auch
getan hat Frau würdig sind sie
beunruhigt über die Lage grundsätzlich
oder jetzt darauf bzw grundsätzlich
natürlich man ist ich glaube es als
Bürgerin oder als Bürger ist man
natürlich
beunruhigt wenn man das Gefühl hat dass
die Menschen die das Land eigentlich
leiten sollen selbst die ganze Zeit am
stolpern und am korrekt also am
Korrekturlesen sind das ist natürlich
nicht das was sich erfahren möchte ich
möchte jemand haben der mir jetzt sagt
wo es langgeht auf der anderen Seite
zeigt es auch wiederum dass es nur
Menschen sind und das ist eine
Ausnahmesituation ist und dass der Stein
jetzt immer mehr ins Rollen kommt aber
macht jetzt nicht so Spaß die Zeitung zu
lesen nein das beunruhigt sehr ja
wer könnte denn derjenige sein die
Leitfigur der ist jetzt hinbekommen dass
wir jetzt ich muss auch sagen ich mache
mir auch große Sorgen vor der die
Industrialisierung wie es unseren Firmen
gehen wird wir machen uns ja alle große
Sorgen und ich darf erinnern als wir vor
einem Jahr den Koalitionsvertrag
aufgesetzt hatten da ahnten wir nicht
dass der 24.2 kommen wird Krieg in der
Ukraine und das sich vor allem die
Rahmenbedingungen die Politik Parameter
dementsprechend so verändern werden wir
haben bewusst beim entlastungspak ich
drei ja gesagt wir tun was für die
bedürftige Menschen in unserem Land wir
tun was für die Mitte in unserem Land
zum Beispiel Abschaffung der kalten
Progression aber wir tun auch was für
den Mittelstand also für Unternehmen für
Betriebe vor allem für energieintensive
Betriebe
kein Unternehmen kann heute sagen kein
Unternehmer kann heute sagen kein
selbstverständiger kann heute sagen wo
er in zwölf Monaten ist darüber muss man
sich im Klaren sein selbst Betriebe wo
die Geschäftsmodelle funktionieren wo
das Unternehmen kerngesund ist durch die
veränderten Rahmenbedingungen
beispielsweise Energiepreise ist im
Grunde genommen alles in der Schieflage
geraten da muss die Politik was tun wir
werden ja gleich noch ich habe ja auch
noch mal ein Thema mitgebracht das hat
auch viel was damit zu tun aber darüber
machen wir uns natürlich große Sorgen es
ist völlig richtig die gasumlage die
gasumlage ist eine Fehlkonstruktion
Herr Habeck der Wirtschaftsminister ist
beauftragt eine gasumlage ins Leben zu
rufen das hatte er sich vorgenommen
gehabt aber dann haben wir dann haben
wir gemeinsam festgestellt dass das eine
Fehlkonstruktion gibt aber wir hatten
ganz klar den Auftrag gegeben eine
gasumlage ins Leben zu rufen wo a die
Systemrelevanz der Unternehmen
berücksichtigt wird berücksichtigt
werden und B vor allem Unternehmen und
davon profitieren die auch
wirtschaftlich in einer Schieflage sind
er ist derzeit dabei diese Konstruktion
Fehlkonstruktion zu reparieren
Verlängerung ich muss sagen
ich muss sagen aber im Grunde genommen
ist das wirklich weil das ist die
Aufgabe des Wirtschaftsministers aber
der Wirtschaftsminister ich bin ich bin
zuversichtlich dass der
Wirtschaftsminister in den nächsten
Tagen auch uns ein Modell präsentieren
wird sind sie zuversichtlich ja ich bin
zuversichtlich
die FDP der Druck gemacht dass es kommt
was heißt was heißt Druck gemacht
ich könnte das jetzt ganz billig machen
und sagen das ist der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister aber das ist das
wäre einfach zu billig das in der Form
zu sagen wir sind in einer Koalition und
wir sind als Land in einer wirklich
außerordentlich schwierigen Situationen
nicht nur in Deutschland sondern in ganz
Europa und da sind wir alle gut beraten
nicht parteipolitisch zu denken sondern
erst das Land dann die Partei und das
gilt für alle sowohl aus meiner Sicht
sowohl in der Koalition und das sollte
auch in der Opposition so gelten das
haben sie schön gesagt hätte dieser Reim
mal sehen ob Herr Kistler das auch diese
Harmonie dieses Wohlbefinden jetzt
weiterführt in gar keiner Weise wirklich
nicht überhaupt nicht also ich habe mein
komplettes Vertrauen verloren sowohl in
Herrn Habig als Ron Herrn Scholz muss
ich leider sagen bis heute war der
Beziehungsstatus von mir und Robert
Habeck es ist kompliziert seit heute
sind wir getrennte Leute das muss ich
leider sagen er hat gesagt ich muss noch
mal sagen es ist eine unterirdische
Aussage er hat gesagt wenn wir Glück
haben und guten Winter haben haben wir
eine Chance durch den Winter zu kommen
das heißt es wird offenbar ein Wetter
Schamane jetzt gesucht der also gut
Wetter macht im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und dann
haben wir eine Chance dass eine
indiskutable Aussage für ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ein
Industrienation ich muss mittlerweile
sagen er kann es einfach nicht ich habe
ihm immer verteidigt bis heute habe
gesagt er müht sich er macht seine
Zweifel nach aber nie so alt
kann krisen-scholz kann nur Scholz habe
ich geschrieben kann man nachlesen er
kann mittlerweile weder Krise noch habeg
er kann nur Vertrauen zerstören es wird
ständig mit Hochdruck an irgendwelchen
Dingen gearbeitet die angeblich längst
schon entschieden worden sind herr
Schulz geht vor die Presse und sagt wir
haben im Dezember schon angefangen da
war die CDU noch viel zu doof dass als
Problem zu erkennen wir haben jetzt
september und die Probleme die herr
Scholz im Dezember vergangenen Jahres
schon erkannt haben will sind bis heute
nicht gelöst habe geht vor die Presse
mit Plänen danach merkt man oh
verfassungsrechtlich geht's vielleicht
nicht danach merkt man oh jemand haben
wir vergessen müssen wir nachbessern ich
dachte das nachbesser und das suboptimal
fungieren wer ein Kennzeichen gewesen
der Ära Merkel jetzt kehrt es zurück
unter dieser Ampelkoalition des Grauens
ich bin wirklich enttäuscht das schöne
ist Herr Jägerei hat ja eine Lösung
heute mitgebracht was man jetzt schon
mal tun könnte bei der Energiekrise ja
auf jeden Fall
in ganz Europa wird derzeit über die
Energie über das Thema Energie
gesprochen die Haushalte die Unternehmen
machen sich Sorgen wie es im Herbst oder
Winter weitergeht Energiesicherheit
Energieversorgung das ist Thema Nummer
eins und die Länder die Staaten in der
Europäische Union haben sich gegenseitig
versprochen in dieser schwierigen Zeit
zusammen zu sein sich solidarisch zu
verhalten und sich auch gegenseitig in
einer möglichen Energiekrise zu
unterstützen nur ein Land verhält sich
derzeit aus meiner Sicht nicht
solidarisch das ist Deutschland denn
Deutschland möchte im Grunde genommen
wenn man wenn man hört was der
Wirtschaftsminister sagt von dem
Instrument der Laufzeitverlängerung
nicht gebrauch machen und ich finde in
der jetzigen Situation genau das
Gegenteil der Fall sein die drei noch am
Netz verfügbaren Kernkraftwerke müssen
aus meiner Sicht länger laufen bis 2024
das ist ein Instrument um die
Energiekrise in Deutschland zu
verhindern
Herr börsbach was hat die Union uns da
angetan weil das kann ich jetzt wirklich
nicht der FDP anlasten eigentlich dass
die Atomkraftwerke das würde darüber
heute überhaupt debattieren müssen nein
erst hatten wir den Ausstieg dann kam
die neue Koalition dann haben wir die
Verlängerung dann kam Fukushima dann kam
der Ausstieg insofern ist ihre
Beschreibung jedenfalls am Ende
zutreffend und wir würden wahrscheinlich
heute anders entscheiden was ich jetzt
sage ist jetzt nicht besonders
freundlich aber ich war ja dabei so war
das kein einziger Ministerpräsident
wollte noch an der an der Kernkraft
festhalten keine einzige das gilt
übrigens auch für Volker Bouffier damals
ministerpräsident Horst Seehof in Bayern
die alle in ihren Bundesländern
Kernkraftwerke haben es war nicht Frau
Merkel alleine es war aber auch die
Hoffnung mit der Kehrtwende noch die
Landtagswahl in Baden-Württemberg
gewinnen zu können seitdem ist herr
Kretschmann Ministerpräsident
ja wir können jetzt wieder Vertrauen auf
die Seite der Union ziehen
zurückgewinnen in der Sache stimme ich
Herrn joserei völlig zu aber aus einem
etwas anderen Grund wir sollten alles
unterlassen was dazu führt dass Gas
verbrannt wird zur Stromerzeugung und
zwar aus zwei Gründen Gas ist knapp wir
sollten es für Wärme brauchen oder für
die Produktion und Gas ist teuer solange
wirrit order-prinzip haben bestimmt die
teuerste Form der Energieversorgung den
Preis für alle anderen auch für die
preiswerten
energieerzeugungsformen Sonne und Wind
da gibt es ja auch zufallsgewinne die
jetzt abgeschöpft werden sollen also
dass der eine Grund der andere Grund
weil Gas immer teurer wird gibt es immer
höhere Zusatzgewinne bei den anderen
ohne dass deren Produktionskosten
gestiegen sind das haben wir aber eine
Frage angenommen nur aus pädagogischen
Gründen unterstellt die Union bringt
einen Antrag ein zur Verlängerung
Laufzeit bis Ende 24 dann noch am Netz
befind Kernkraftwerke
würden Sie dem zustimmen also zunächst
einmal die Union hatte ja vor einigen
Wochen diesen Antrag gestellt und ich
habe mich obwohl ich der Koalition oder
einer koalitionsfraktion angehöre hat
mich dort enthalten allerdings wissen
sie auch sie wissen ganz genau wie das
funktioniert wenn ein Antrag der
Opposition kommt aber ein Antrag der
Ampel ich bin ja es ist echtes Beispiel
aber
Endphase in der Endphase ja genau
allerdings muss man sagen das ist das
ist trotzdem das ist das ist ein Thema
da kommen wir nicht drumherum
das ist jetzt das ist jetzt ein
Nebenschauplatz da sollten wir jetzt
nicht hingehen wichtig ist dass diese
Koalition bei dem Thema tatsächlich von
dem Instrument der Laufzeitverlängerung
Gebrauch macht wir verhalten uns in ganz
Europa derzeit unsolidarisch ich möchte
das BürgerInnen fragen warum stimmt man
dann jetzt gar nicht um sie inzeln aber
warum enthält man sich dann wenn man
aber eigentlich dem Antrag der
Opposition zustimmt vom Herzen her das
ist eine Frage der der koalitionstechnik
und Disziplin bei mir ist das in der
Regel sehr sehr oft so dass ich
inhaltlich sehr nah bin an den
Positionen der der Union
Bundestagsfraktion aber nicht desto
trotz wenn man einmal damit anfängt es
ist jetzt unabhängig von welchem Thema
dann hat auch eine Koalition keinen Sinn
mehr dann ist auf bricht auch eine
Regierung schnell zusammen das heißt
dann werden Sie auch bei anderen Themen
nicht mehr handlungsfähig sein deswegen
ist es an der Stelle nicht eine Frage
der Technik sondern das ist hier eine
inhaltliche Debatte die muss diese
Koalition führen und ich erwarte vom
deutschen Wirtschaftsminister dass er an
der Stelle die Interessen des Landes im
Blick hat
es denn Herr jirzerei das Herr Habeck
noch die Kehrtwende macht
Herr Habeck wird aus meiner Sicht nicht
Politik machen gegen Physik
wir
natürlich spielen wahltaktische Gründe
hier eine Rolle weil auch eine
Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen gibt und
man habe auch dort hofft vor allem weil
die Grünen in Niedersachsen ja auch sehr
aktiv das Thema also gegen
Kernkraftwerke sich auch als Thema
positioniert
genau und von daher
spielt das an der Stelle eine Rolle aber
wie kommt er nicht drumherum wir sind
unten den Menschen in Deutschland
verpflichtet bei dem Thema voranzukommen
und wir sind auch unseren europäischen
Partnern verpflichtet an der Stelle
Solidarität zu zeigen und ich glaube das
ist auch eine realistische Debatte
niemand sagt hier wie sollen im Bereich
der Kerntechnik jetzt dauerhaft
einsteigen das sagte niemand sondern es
ist nur eine Laufzeitverlängerung bis
Herr Kistler sie haben genickt als er
jäserei geredet weil er sehr präzise die
machttechniken innerhalb einer mehr
parteienkoalition geschrieben hat sehr
ehrlich also sie sind in meiner Achtung
noch etwas mehr gestiegen also muss
jetzt ehrlich sagen dass Sie das sagen
sehr ehrlich auch wirklich ja ich bin
Dauerwerbesendungen
[Gelächter]
gleichwohl ist natürlich die Frage was
erreicht man damit wenn wir dieser
Forderung offenbar am Kabinettstisch
nicht durchtrinken und stattdessen Radio
Interviews gibt in die Öffentlichkeit
geht in Talkshows geht und sagt habe
kommt zu Potte gleichzeitig hören wir
die Aussagen von Prominenten Figuren an
der Spitze der Grünen die immer noch
sagen seine Phantom Debatte die
Geschichte habe ihr endgültiges Urteil
über die Atomenergie gefällt noch dazu
ich mag das Wort ja nicht an dem Fall
stimmt das also alte weiße Männer ihr
Erbe gefährdet sehen und deshalb lieber
die Deindustrialisierung in Kauf nehmen
als eine schlechte Legacy sozusagen und
das ist aber glaube ich die wirklich
entscheidende Frage ist dass du ein
Ausdruck von Stärke der FDP dass sie in
der Öffentlichkeit seine kontraposition
gehen oder Schwäche weil man im Kabinett
sonst überhaupt nichts mehr erreichen
würde Frau würdig sind sie denn als
Bürgerin wenn Sie das Hören auch mit der
taktierung in der Politik was denken sie
denn ich fand das schon spannend ich
glaube auch dass das wenn ich das jetzt
so richtig
gefiltert habe hier das ist schon an der
Zeit wird und da kriegt dem kann ich
auch nur zustimmen dass jetzt
ministerpolitik gemacht wird und nicht
Parteipolitik
also ich glaube es gibt doch Umfragen
die Wähler und Wähler der Grünen sehen
das etwas anders und die können sich
mehrheitlich darum geht es ja eine
befristete Verlängerung Angesicht der
katastrophalen Situation auf dem
Energiemarkt vorstellt aber die grüne
Basis sieht das wohl etwas
Niedersachsen auch anders die kommen ja
aus der Friedensbewegung aber seit
neuestem wissen wir das stolze
kriegsdienstverweigereren Waffen für die
Ukraine rufen das hörte sie auch früher
ganz anders an und jetzt soll noch das
zweite Megaprojekt anders laufen als
ursprünglich geplant ist natürlich für
die grüne Seele schwierig
nein wir haben nur Ölheizung aber leute
es geht um 82 Millionen Menschen es geht
um den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
es geht um Familienhaushalte die mit dem
Rücken zur Wand stehen und wenn das die
da sind wir uns ja eigentlich in der
Beschreibung der Situation da muss ich
mal sagen ist mir die Gemütslage der
Grünen Basis relativ egal und habe
riskiert wirklich vom Acker ja zu werden
weil er geht nun persönlich mit dieser
Energiepolitik nach Hause und wenn es
wirklich ansatzweise an Blackout käme
wäre das wirklich an seinen
Verantwortung dann werden die Grünen für
Jahr
also Süddeutsche Zeitung ist Kistler
gerade
vorne drauf der Mann der den
Unternehmern die Krise erklärt steht in
dem Text drin würde ich sagen da fehlt
dann auch die Einblendung dauerwerbes
Jahr also das ist ja wirklich total was
nur noch Kabarett also ich glaube man
muss sich wirklich den Fakten annähern
und wir haben eine eine energiemangelage
und wenn Herr Habig selber sagt es kann
schon nutzen wenn du dich weniger duscht
aber es nutzt nichts wenn ein
Atomkraftwerk mehr läuft dann ist es ein
so derartig großer gucken tiefer
Widerstand da kommt ja keine Süddeutsche
drüber hinweg also bis vor kurzem hieß
es übrigens auch wir haben gar keinen
Strom Problem in Deutschland das darf
man auch nicht vergessen das ist auch
von einigen Seiten aber ich will es noch
mal ganz klar an dieser Stelle sagen ich
bin bereit oder auch sage ich auch als
Generalsekretär der FDP ich bin bereit
diesen Streit innerhalb der Koalition
auszutragen ich weiß nicht wie wie das
ausgeht wird
auch diese Frage ist berechtigt nur ich
weiß ganz genau sie wissen das auch dass
diese Koalition natürlich
außerordentlich schwierig ist für die
FDP und Streit innerhalb der Koalition
ist ein gutes Bild haben wir am Ende
angekommen wir nehmen sie aber
wir nehmen sie aber
sind wir jetzt am Ende angekommen
tschüss schönen Abend noch bis morgen
[Musik]